Nope.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange focus channel.
My name is Paul.
Thank you for tuning in.
Today we're going to talk about some
famous people who can't speak a foreign
language.
When we think of famous people are
iconic people,
the image in mind that we have of them,
it's usually just a very thin slice of
who they are.
We know the skills and the talents that
they choose to share with the public,
but there are always other things about
them that we don't know and that most of
us would find surprising.
A lot of us would be surprised to know
that one of the famous celebrities that
we look up to can speak a foreign
language.
Now,
there are some famous celebrities who
grew up speaking foreign languages.
For example.
Well,
Natalie Portman was born in Jerusalem
and she is fluent in Hebrew.
Good.
And Leonardo Dicaprio speaks German
because his family on his mother's side
is from Germany,
not mine,
almost from a [inaudible],
uh,
switched him to Vec from Dusseldorf.
But there are also lots of famous people
who have learned foreign languages as
teens or adults.
One example is will Smith who speak
Spanish?
Let's have a look.
No,
uh,
and up to two zero k and this is
[inaudible].
Okay,
so maybe we'll smith doesn't seem
completely fluent in Spanish,
but that's all right.
He seems to have the basics down.
He has a working knowledge of Spanish.
He is on record as saying that he
studies Spanish in order to do
interviews for his fans around the world
who speak Spanish.
I think the lesson we can take from will
smith is that having a very specific
functional goal in mind for the
language,
having a real functional reason to use
the language is a great external
motivator to study it.
Maybe he doesn't have a personal
cultural interest in studying Spanish,
but that professional goal of giving
interviews in Spanish motivates him to
study and he's constantly improving.
So I think it's working.
Another person is Bradley Cooper who was
fluent in French.
Let's take a look.
Mia,
CBL plumbism he posted,
oh,
sit by me buck to us.
It didn't new laws,
they've got more superpose you have a
bubble set us up.
[inaudible]
now,
Bradley Cooper clearly speaks French
very well.
He often gives interviews in the French
Press,
the French media.
He says that he studied abroad in France
when he was a teenager.
He lived there for six months and was
basically immersed in the French
language.
So I think the lesson that we can take
from Bradley Cooper is that living in
the country where that language is
spoken,
living amongst people who speak it with
you everyday,
being immersed is one of the best ways
that you can solidify your language
skills.
Another person is Gwyneth paltrow who
speaks fluent Spanish.
Let's take a look
[inaudible] job,
eh,
we're not.
I own opportunity Spania as to the Rie.
What does paltrow says that she went to
Mexico when she was a teenager and she
fell in love with the country and she
started to study the language and that
she's been back there on a regular basis
ever since then.
And even to this day,
she still speaks Spanish regularly and
she says she even speak Spanish to her
kids sometimes.
So I think what we can learn from her is
that really falling in love with a
culture and making that culture a part
of your life and a part of who you are
is a great way to also get motivated to
study that language and make the
language a part of yourself and your
life.
It's not really difficult to do that if
you love the culture,
you don't even need to push yourself
because you'll always just enjoy
studying that language and enjoy getting
to know the culture even more than you
currently do.
Now the next person is not a movie star,
not a Hollywood star,
but she's still very famous and you
still know who she is and that's jk
rowling,
who was the author of the Harry Potter
Series Of course,
and she is filthy fucking rich.
Jk Rowling,
can't speak French,
let's have a look.
Good idea because you're pulling slam
every t [inaudible] apple in
significance to particularly air it say
personnel.
Constable explicate on stone.
Jk Rowling majored in French in
university and part of her program was
to spend a year abroad in Paris studying
the language and she was also a French
teacher in the UK for a while before she
became filthy rich.
So similar to Bradley Cooper.
I think the lesson that we can learn
from jk rowling is that immersion in the
country will immersion amongst the
language that you want to learn is one
of the best ways to solidify your skills
and to become good at that language.
Another lesson that we can learn from
her is that learning a foreign language
will make you filthy rich.
Well,
maybe not,
but hey,
I can dream right,
and this last person is also not a
Hollywood star,
but this person is huge and it is mark
Zuckerberg.
Of course,
we all know mark Zuckerberg is the
founder of facebook and he made big
headlines last year by speaking at a
conference in China in Mandarin.
He actually did an interview with an
interviewer in Mandarin for about 30
minutes.
Let's take a look.
You're jumping in.
She jumped.
She kind of,
okay,
so it doesn't seem like mark is
completely fluent in Mandarin,
but he seems to have the basics down.
He's got a working knowledge of the
language.
He seems to be able to answer questions
and express himself so it is what it is.
He'll continue to improve.
I'm sure.
I don't know how he studied or studies
the language,
but his reasons for studying the
language are interesting and those are
lessons in and of themselves.
His first reason for studying the
language is that his wife is of Chinese
descent and he wants to communicate with
her family,
so that shows us that having a specific
group of people that you really want to
communicate with in that language,
that's a great motivator to push you to
learn the language.
His second reason for learning the
language is that China is a great
country,
a great culture and a great civilization
and he wants to learn more about it.
I think what he says that that's a
veiled way of saying that he wants to
get facebook into China because it's
such an important place,
but if we take what he says at face
value,
then of course wanting to know more
about an important culture is a great
motivation,
but if his main point is to get facebook
into China than that too,
that kind of goal,
having an important business goal like
that,
that is also a powerful external
motivator to get you studying a
language.
His third reason for studying mandarin
is that he enjoys challenges and he
thinks mandarin is a challenging
language.
Now,
think about that attitude for a second.
That's really an attitude of success.
If you think that challenge is bad,
if you think that anything difficult or
anything that makes you uncomfortable as
bad,
then you're going to shy away from
learning a language because it's
sometimes necessary to break out of your
comfort zone to learn a language.
But if you embrace that,
if you see that as getting yourself
fired up for,
you know,
as making yourself more powerful by
fighting through some kind of challenge
of difficulty than that,
that's just an attitude that can propel
you forward rather than making you shy
away from learning a language.
None of these people are known mainly
for their language skills,
right?
They're all known mainly for some other
talent or skill or creation that they've
contributed to the world and they're all
really quite busy focusing on those
things.
But the fact that they can become good
at a foreign language,
even though they're focused on this
other central goal that shows you that
you can do it too.
So take them as examples.
People we can learn from people we can
be inspired by and motivated by.
A lot of people like to watch famous
people and observe their lives,
but don't just watch them as observers.
I want you to actually learn something
from them and emulate the good qualities
of those people are right.
This is Paul from length focus.
I hope you enjoyed this video.
Have a nice night.
Talk to you later in French has been the
easiest language that I have personally
studied.
I used to think it was Indonesian
because Indonesia is really simple.
In the future.
Beyond that,
you can see the next goal in front of
you,
which is to start learning Spanish or
whatever your language of interest
gives,
but just think of it like that.
Like you're not discarding those goals
are discarding those missions you are.
You were kind of putting them off into
the future and you'll get to them later.
But your primary mission right now is
this one.
What you need to accomplish first before
you can get to that future mission.